you
you
hi so I'm going to talk about cross-site
scripting and I'm going to talk about
ways that you can mitigate the risk the
cross-site scripting is actually going
to affect you my name is my quest i work
on chrome at Google ideas himself in
blink I do some stuff in chromium happy
to talk about any of that after this
talk it's really exciting stuff I like
chrome a lot I think you guys should too
you can go to my website you can find me
on google+ on Twitter whatever this page
isn't exercise and seeing how many times
i can write my quest on a single slide i
think i haven't yet hit the limit there
could be an email to the slides are up
online right now and actually you know
what I forgot to make them public but
they will be up online in just a moment
there on speaker deck which is awesome I
suggest that you all use speaker dock if
you ever do slides so it's after lunch
you guys have eaten a lot of food you're
probably very very tired you have room
in your brains for one thing and if you
only have room in your brains for one
thing I would highly suggest that it be
this thing I'd really appreciate it if
you just hit this article it talks about
content security policy what is content
security policy why should you care
don't worry about it right now I'll tell
you but please just bookmark this
article take a look at it it's going to
give you all of the practical
information in all the detail that I'm
going to have to leave out in this talk
because this talks like a half hour long
and I could talk for days no one wants
that take a look at the article I think
it's really important that I think would
be really helpful for you how many of
you have ever seen a page that looks
kind of like this in chrome or any other
browser that's not enough of you your
people are browsing boring boring
websites you need to branch out there is
so much of the web that you can explore
and you can get this page more often
you're not going to see this from you
know CNN com you got to dig around a
little bit this is a malware page or a
malware warning brought to you by the
magic of safe browsing Safe Browsing is
a service that google puts out it's used
by Firefox it's used by chrome and a
variety of other services non browser
services also to determine whether or
not a page is persistently malicious
that is whether the page is always
serving malware or always directing
people to phishing sites we've gotten
really good at detecting these sorts of
persistent
threats it's relatively easy for us to
crawl the entire web and say well this
page no I don't like it too much this
other page it's great what we're not so
good at are detecting the more transient
threats the threats that have effect
only a single request or only a single
logged in user or only all logged in
users for a service it's very difficult
to detect those sorts of things content
injection attacks in particular are
incredibly scary I'll tell you why
they're scary in a moment but they're
very very difficult for us to detect
because generally speaking content
injection attacks come from for instance
bad parsing of get parameters and if
someone sends you an email with a
carefully crafted URL that you click on
and that owns you in some way it's very
difficult for us to detect that it's
very difficult for us to warn you about
that content injection is scary because
of this concept the concept of an origin
an origin is a pairing of a scheme a
host and a port so HTTP example.com 80
and HTTPS google com 443 those are two
distinct origins and the browser is very
good at effectively making sure that
example.com never has direct access to
any data from google com the origin
boundary is a boundary that the browser
can very effectively enforce but that's
the only boundary that the browser can
very effectively enforce the entire web
is basically predicated upon the concept
of the same origin policy or security on
the web is predicated on this concept
and this basically means that one origin
should only have access to the data for
that origin it should only have access
to its own cookies through its own local
storage to its own databases and so on
and this is something again that the
browser can quite effectively enforce
what is the difference between these two
blocks of script that is exactly right
there is no difference whatsoever to the
browser visually we can inspect both of
these and we can say the first of these
script blocks is awesome I really want
to execute that the second one I have no
idea how they got on my page I don't
want to be evil come on this is
craziness it might of course have gotten
on my page because I did something like
that
because I let the user define their own
name and then I write the name out
directly without any sort of escaping if
the user calls themself open script tag
be evil closed script tag that i have a
problem because i've just injected code
into my origin and again the browser
cannot distinguish between code that i
meant to execute and code that I didn't
mean to execute content injection
attacks are dangerous because they trick
the server into serving content on its
own origin that's going to do users harm
and to do the application harm these are
all of the contexts in which an HTML
page can find itself or data and an HTML
page can find itself there's a style tag
so I I'll put a color into style and put
a name into a paragraph i put a URL
directly into an attribute and an
element i put an ID in the script and
maybe i have some debug information
inside of a comment the rules for
escaping in all of these contexts are
distinct for example inside of an HDL
HTML comment two dashes will close the
comment and everything after those two
dashes will be rendered two dashes
inside of a paragraph of course has no
effect whatsoever it just renders the
two dashes now escaping is actually
quite trivial the rules are easy all you
have to do is do it perfectly every
single time for every piece of data that
you have ever you just have to be
perfect it's not that hard right these
problems are trivial but unfortunately
we are incredibly bad at trivial things
if you look at the history of the web
everyone has content injection holes on
their website google has holes you have
holes it's simply a pervasive problem on
the web it's one that we absolutely need
to work on and frameworks are giving us
the possibilities to do this there are
context-aware escaping mechanisms
they've been around since 2009 at least
we're simply not using them and when we
do use then we're not using them well we
should use them better nothing i'm going
to tell you today is going to stop you
from the necessity of actually escaping
your data correctly what i'd like to do
today is to explain to you how you can
mitigate the risk or mitigate the impact
of the holes that are absolutely going
to be on your site for instance does
anyone know a wasp owa SP okay a wasp is
great and it you seem to know who it is
i'll just say it's a security they do
security trainings they do a variety of
security sorts of stuff and this is a
really good resource for you when you
want to learn about the variety of ways
in which people can inject things into
your website these are kind of tricky
things you might not think about when
you're putting things down for example
you could have an entity that doesn't
have a semicolon at the end you just
have to Pat it out to the right length
so if you're checking for entities by
looking for ampersand semicolon then
you're doing yourself with the service
because that's not actually how HTML has
to work ray for HTML lots of exciting
rules if you ever heard of jazz [ __ ] is
modern in the audience somewhere No ok
you'll probably hear about a little bit
later Jess [ __ ] is awesome it proves
that you can express any JavaScript
statement with only six characters open
parenthesis close parentheses plus
square brace close square brace and bang
with these six characters you can write
any JavaScript statement that's kind of
amazing right it's very exciting but all
of these characters are relatively
benign and I doubt that any of your
filters are actually looking at any of
these characters as being particularly
dangerous do we know what this does
actually it's just JavaScript right i
mean this this is pretty straightforward
it's it's alert one exactly it's alert
one usually you do alert xss like the
string but that's about 40,000
characters so i didn't feel like pacing
it in here jsbach is many things among
them it is verbose Alex Russell puts
this absolutely beautifully he says I
discount the probability of perfection
and he's right it's really hard to be
perfect it's really easy to make small
mistakes and unfortunately small
mistakes are all that it takes in order
for a hole to be created on our site and
one hole is all of it till it takes poor
data to be exfiltrated to a malicious
third party so I would rephrase this
slightly I would say we are all idiots
with deadlines we simply don't do the
right thing and we don't do the right
thing not because we don't know it's the
right thing not because we're
trying to do the right thing but because
we'd have other priorities we have
deadlines we have things that are
important we need to build this new
feature we need to build this new page
and somehow securing the other pages and
securing the page that we're building
kind of falls through the cracks it's
kind of assumed that you're doing good
security work so again it's really
important for us to have the ability to
mitigate the effect of the holes that
we're going to create saimin know what
this picture is or what this painting is
one person two people culture people
come on culture this is Odysseus in the
sirens it's from the Odyssey which is a
very very old book indeed the story is
something like this the sirens sing
beautifully so beautifully in fact that
once you hear their song all you want to
do is hear more of this beautiful music
it drives you to the brink of madness
and since they live on an island it
particularly drill it drives sailors to
the brink of madness who come you know
somewhere near the island generally you
want to hear more of the music so you
throw yourself overboard in order to get
to this island generally the ship will
crash the sirens I guess eat people who
knows and because of that the sirens are
incredibly dangerous and sailors know to
avoid this island and to avoid you know
beautiful music you hear music go away
because you're probably going to try to
kill yourself shortly afterwards
Odysseus however is an incredible man he
is an egomaniac and he's incredibly
hubristic and because of this he says I
am going to be the only living person
who has ever heard this song I love
music and I really want to hear this but
I don't want to throw myself overboard
so how can I work around this well after
talking to a which he comes up with an
amazing plan and this plan is as follows
he tells his men to bind him to the mast
tie his hands behind his back tie his
legs to the mast so he can't get away
but he can hear music and he can talk to
people so I guess that's nice he then
tells his men to put a beeswax in their
ears and then bind their head such that
they can't actually hear anything that's
going on around them and he gives them
very explicit instructions he says you
know row in this direction don't go to
that Island over there just kind of go
around it don't throw yourself overboard
and just you know keep going forwards
they go
the island he's driven to the brink of
madness by this beautiful music but he
survives he survives because he
prevented his men from doing things that
would harm them all it'd be really nice
if your application could tell the
browser not to do things that's going to
harm the application perhaps that this
piece of JavaScript is what I want you
to ask you please execute this piece of
JavaScript do it as quickly as you
possibly can but don't look at these
other pieces of JavaScript or rather
look at them but please do not touch
right don't execute this stuff content
security policy is this thing I think
it's beautiful it's not beautiful but
you know it's really helpful I edit the
specification along with Adam Barth and
Dan bennetts from google and mozilla
respectively they basically just tell me
what to type and I type it because they
are much smarter than I am but I have
the opportunity to be here with you so
you know I think I get the better
portion of that deal regardless content
security policy is a language that
defines a mechanism by which you can
give a whitelist to a browser and say
script from this origin awesome script
from that origin not so much please
execute this do not execute that it
gives you exciting errors like this
refuse to load the script example.com
evil j/s because it violates the
following content security policy
directive script source self will talk
about what exactly that means in a
moment this is what a Content security
policy directive or a policy looks like
it's an HTTP header delivered when you
deliver the page it contains a semicolon
separated list of directives each
directive giving you control granular
control over a particular type of
content this is the policy for an
incredibly high value website my quest
or you may have heard of it it's really
really important you should all visit it
we start by setting a default source of
none which basically means for all the
types of content that content security
policy gives you control over load none
of it none is the only acceptable origin
which means don't load any content then
we slowly open that up and we say okay
load no content except style for my CDN
and you can also open frames from these
sources you can open some script and
execute it
then you can open some images from over
here so what we've done here is
basically started with a closed door and
then only let in those types of content
and those origins of content that we
actually trust now what I'm showing here
or just origins it's actually the case
that both chrome and firefox support the
1.1 syntax which allows you to have
paths so you can say not only only
script for my CDN but only script for my
CDN that's in this particular directory
or even only this particular file if you
want to be that granular gives you a lot
of control and although I don't think
most people will be that granular there
is a lot of value to doing so if you
want to this is a relatively exhaustive
list of all the directives that are in
one point 0 will go through as many of
them as we possibly can the ones that
you haven't seen yet are things like
connect source which determines where
you can make xhr requests and also
events source and things along those
lines and sandbox which allows you to
apply a sandboxing policy to the
document that's being loaded on a page
you've heard of iframe sandboxing I hope
and if you haven't you'll hear about it
at the end of the talk sandbox directive
allows you to apply a sandbox to the
page that's currently loading which you
don't currently have the option of doing
it's actually quite powerful what you
also see at the bottom there is report
URI report your eye is very important it
allows you to find out when your site is
being attacked if you have a policy on
your site and there's a violation
because the script was injected that you
didn't expect this gives you a post back
to a specific endpoint on your origin
and this post contains some useful
information it tells you what document
was being attacked it tells you what the
attack kind of looked like what the
source file was if we can find a line
number and a column number for you will
do so and we'll give you that
information so that you can start
figuring out where the holes are on your
website what you see at the top here is
content security policy report only so
what we have is the ability not only to
enforce a policy but also to have a
report policy happening at the same time
so you can you can slowly roll this out
on your websites by first reporting
violations and then moving to
enforcement once you think you've closed
all the holes this gives you the ability
to also have two policies active at the
same time one relatively loose policy
that you enforce for exam
people https only and one policy that's
a little bit stricter that you put in
report only mode for a little while
until you're confident that your site
actually matches the policy that you've
written now some people don't like
content security policy so much there
are really two things to complaints that
I've heard about content security policy
actually before I get into this who in
the audience was familiar with content
security policy before this talk okay a
couple of people that's actually quite
good has anyone implemented secondo
security policy on their websites okay a
couple of people please talk to me
afterwards we very much want feedback
we're still in the process of doing 1.1
and any feedback that we can get is good
feedback so Rick waldron CSP designed by
ignoring reality so there are two things
that Rick believes are ignoring reality
and I kind of agree with them we want to
change reality we have looked at reality
and we kind of don't like it so much so
we've invented our own and we're trying
to roll it out as well as we possibly
can one piece of reality that is
problematic are inline scripts inline
scripts are the biggest problem on the
web period but the biggest problem on
the web because well what origin does
this come from it comes from your origin
right but if we allow self then that's
not only inline script on your origin
but also external script from your
origin so we've invented a new origin
for this called unsafe inline we call it
unsafe inline because it's kind of
unsafe and we kind of don't want you to
use it so please don't but if you want
to you can whitelist it haha what we
would suggest however is that you
externalize the scripts to whatever
extent possible you pull it out into an
external file the browser can verify
that this file is coming from an origin
that you've trust that you trust and
then it will execute on the page so I
need to do something like this where you
externalise the file you just inbound
manipulation to attach event handlers
and you go from there What's in 1.1 that
we think is going to be a better
solution well actually what we've done
in one point 0 is basically thrown out
the baby with the bathwater right we
know that there are good uses of inline
script we know that it's performance we
know that there are some latency issues
however in order to get something out
the door that's useful
you've thrown all that out as well
inline script is just banned by default
in 1.1 we're kind of going to look in
the water and see what babies we can
pick back up and hopefully we can get a
couple of them because babies are nice
one thing that we're trying to do in
order to allow certain types of inline
script is using a nonce you send the
nonce as a valid origin in a script
source this nonce is then repeated as a
nonce attribute on scripts that come
into a page this allows the browser to
distinguish between scripts that the
page inject it that is if the page knows
the secret it can execute the script and
if an attacker hopefully doesn't know
the secret then it won't be able to
execute script because they won't be
able to get access to the nonce this is
one thing that might work pretty well
there's another proposal being made by
Twitter Neil mattel who's doing a great
job putting together some additional
pieces of this pack that will be doing
hashing so we'll basically send a shot
to shot 356 hash as a valid source and
then if a script that matches that hash
appears in line then we'll execute it so
there's still a lot of work to do in
order to make sure that these two figure
out which of these we actually want to
implement and then to actually spec them
out and implement them nonces are
available right now in chrome so if you
go into chrome flags turn on
experimental web platform features you
can start playing around with nonces
right now we think that's going to be
relatively effective and what's nice
about nonces they have the property that
they're transferable so you can if for
instance you embed an ad into your page
which many people do then you can give
the ad network the the nonce is a get
parameter and then they can inject
script into origin as well so for a lot
of use cases this transfer ability is
very powerful it gives you more of a
system of capabilities by which this non
skeeves you the ability to execute
script or put style in line we think
that has some good properties the other
thing that ignores reality is eval eval
is problematic because if you allow
people or people will be able to inject
things onto your page and if you read
data from your page and then eval it
you're opening yourself up to potential
attack vectors so it's more reflective
dhamma talk as opposed to just something
coming directly from a get parameter we
then eval by default as well you can
turn it back on by allowing the
the unsafe eval origin again unsay if we
kind of don't like it but if you really
need it then go for it I think there are
better mechanisms by which into eval
eval is problematic because it executes
in the context of your origin just like
every other piece of script in your site
you can get around this with Stan boxing
there's a good article written by a very
handsome man that explains how you can
inject an iframe into your page sandbox
the iframe such that a it's not coming
from the same origin and be that it
doesn't have any permissions that it
doesn't need it can execute script and
that's basically it you can pass
information into this script or into
this iframe it can do some processing
and then give you some data back and if
the if the processing is exploited
within the context of that iframe even
if you then eject like inner HTML with
the data that you get back that's
protected by the policy of the larger
page so the iframe doesn't have a policy
it but it's sandboxed your page has a
policy which means pass information
throw it over the wall get something
useful back and then do something with
it and you don't have to trust that
relationship and if it executes bad code
then that's kind of okay because it
didn't have access to any of your useful
data so i'd highly recommend that you at
least take a look at this there's a demo
here that shows you how eval works
within the context of an iframe you
basically have an iframe doesn't
processing and it just evals code
directly and then gives you the result
back and you can play around without a
little bit it's a good demo I think of
the concept so I highly recommend that
you take a look I called this talk
actually I'm sorry this is the article
again please read it I think it's really
important this gives you all of the
practical detail that you're going to
need in order to actually start
implementing this on your sites and
that's that's really what I want more
than anything else I want people to
start implementing this and I want those
people to give feedback to the working
group such that we can construct 1.1 in
the way that really meets your needs
instead of needing most of your needs
which is I think where we are right now
I called this talk what did I call this
topic towards a post XSS world and I
called it that because of this article
this is a great article published I
think at the end of two thousand twelve
called postcards from the post XSS world
in other words exciting security
researchers are already figuring out how
they're going to be attacking you once
script is no longer allowed on your site
it is possible it is not that difficult
basically what content security policy
is going to do is allow you more
granular control over the script that
executes on your site over the style
that executes on your site and a variety
of other resource types I'd really
highly recommend that you be as
restrictive as possible in those
resource types however it's still the
case the content injection attacks can
be dangerous they can still exfiltrate
data people are coming up with really
exciting ways of doing things the
metaphor that's used or the analogy
that's used in this document is that
content security policy is kind of like
address space randomization for
applications it doesn't actually prevent
attacks but it raises the bar for
attacks it makes it more difficult and
the more difficult attacks are the more
likely attackers are to move to less
difficult targets which i think is good
so if you're in the woods with your
friends and you see a bear and the bear
rares up on its hind legs and roars at
you and starts running in your direction
you're all going to turn around and run
away you don't want to be the slowest in
that group you want to be the fastest in
that group or at least somewhere in the
middle content security policy gives you
a little bit of burst of speed such that
you are not the easiest target it gives
you a lot of control over the content
that's executed on your site and because
of that it mitigates to a large extent
the impact of the content injection
attacks that are absolutely going to
exist on your sites I highly recommend
you take a look at it thank you for your
time
you